All right, moving on
to our top story,
Societal malignant tumor
George Zimmerman.
George Zimmerman
is selling the gun he used
to kill unarmed teenager
Trayvon Martin,
placing it up for auction
online today.
Yep.
This is America, everybody.
Um... I'm just
gonna give everyone
a home minute
to pick up any items
you may have just thrown
at your television set.
-(laughter)
-Mmm... Pick it up.
Okay, who woke up this rotting
piece of human excrement?
And... and better yet,
why is he doing this?
NEWSMAN: Zimmerman says
he doesn't feel comfortable
simply locking it away.
I would feel very comfortable
simply locking you away.
(laughter, whooping, applause)
It would make me
very comfortable.
You don't have
to lock it away--
you can just throw it
in the trash.
You know, trash?
That thing that you are
and always will be?
-(whooping, applause)
-Right?
God!
All right. What else did
this bloated tank gristle
have to say for himself?
NEWSWOMAN:
Speaking on the phone,
he was unapologetic
about the sale.
Yeah, so why don't you take your
possessions and shoot yourself?
-(applause)
-Just do it.
Okay, guys, and in case
you weren't disgusted enough,
let's take a look
at the original ad
he posted for the gun.
Check out
the "Item Condition-- Used."
-(audience groans)
-Okay?
Now, America...
America...
I need to ask you
a serious question.
What the entire (bleep)?
(laughter)
I mean, and by "used,"
he means the firearm
"was used to defend my life
"and end the brutal attack
from Trayvon Martin.
"It has recently
been returned to me
by the Department of Justice."
And then he says...
Okay, first of all,
"B. Hussein Obama."
I love how racists
can work in a Muslim slam
into any unrelated
conversation, right?
He really killed two birds
with that racist stone.
Of course, then he also claimed
the birds were attacking him.
-(laughter)
-Right?
But reason has no place
in this ad.
Zimmerman even claims
the gun is a hot item
on the museum circuit.
He says...
Okay, first of all,
please do not cast
Michael B. Jordan
for this
Night at the Museum movie.
Please do not do that.
Way too dangerous.
And incidentally, George,
the Smithsonian denies any
interest, you stupid (bleep).
-(laughter, applause, whooping)
-All right?
They're not interested in that.
Okay, now,
it looks like the auction site
has been taken down,
so, yay, America...
(laughter)
But here's why
this gets me so angry.
Every time George Zimmerman
is a trending topic on Twitter,
every time his name
pops up on the news,
every time he takes up any
real estate in my brain at all,
it's a reminder
that he's a free man
who can do
whatever dumb (bleep) he wants
while Trayvon Martin
doesn't get to grow up.
-So tonight...
-(applause)
So tonight I'm thinking
about you, Trayvon,
and not that asshole
that killed you, all right?
And, George Zimmerman,
you can go to Hell.